hey getting drafted into the nfl will
always be one of the most cherished
memories for nfl players
kevin martin caught up with not only a
player who remembers his draft day
but it all led to the hall of fame kevin
well chris nowadays the name anthony
munoz holds a ton of weight in nfl
circles but back in 1980
the two-time all-american lineman out of
usc was considered a high-risk
draft pick because of multiple knee
injuries that only allowed him to play
in
16 total games during his collegiate
career but as we all know now
those concerns were unnecessary you know
what
it was about 100 years ago pro football
hall of famer anthony munoz recalls his
draft day experience
back in 1980. my situation a lot
different than most
i've gone through three knee operations
in my four years my last year my senior
i got hurt in the very first game i had
surgery missed the entire season
played in the rose bowl that was the
only game i played and because munoz
missed almost his entire senior season
at usc
he wasn't projected to be a high draft
pick going into
the draft all the experts were saying i
wouldn't be drafted
i might be a free agent but all i wanted
was a chance to get to an nfl camp
to see if i could compete on that level
but boy did the ontario california
native
prove the draft experts wrong and all it
took was one team and that team happened
to have the third pick in the entire
draft and that was the bengals
and i'm very thankful to paul brown and
the brown family that gave me an
opportunity
not only to go to camp but to go to 13
camps and
and you know as they say the rest is
history 13 seasons 11 pro bowls and a
bust in canton later
anthony munoz is considered one of the
greatest offensive linemen to ever play
in the nfl
so i knew once i was picked with that
third pick that i couldn't
put in cruise control i had to up my
game and conditioning and strengthening
and studying the game
and anthony munoz will be busy for the
cincinnati bengals for this year's draft
as he will announce the team's third
round pick
which will be the 69th overall selection